vous approuvez par exemple la
starification de loana donc quand même
le principal titre de gloire a été
d'abandonner son enfant la dass vous à
vous a prouvé qu'elle de lénine star
énorme provocation 10 ans est le
principal titre de gloire c'est d'avoir
réussi malgré tous les problèmes qu'elle
a eue avant à tenir le coup et pour elle
le loft ça a été super dur au début on
l'a vu et elle a tenu le coup et hans à
chacun quoi chapeau ah ouais chaque au
chapeau parce qu'elle elle a vraiment eu
du mal
chacun a vécu avec sa sensibilité bien
alors on va arrêter un petit peu love
story on va en venir à vous plus
précisément deux fois par semaine donc
le lundi et le vendredi
vous êtes sûr reprendre l'émission de
yann kulik de 10h40 à 12h02 contente
c'est génial alors vous faites une
chronique vous faites une chronique
santé beauté mais ça je crois que c'est
familial je crois que déjà dormi non moi
je suis né dans l'esthétique
oui ma mère à un journal professionnel
d'esthétique donc je suis né dedans
1 depuis toujours et ça ne peut c'est un
créneau qui ne peut que vous intéressez
métropole et j'ai remarqué t rim télé
changer de coiffure sa malfaisance et
quoi mais ça fait bizarre
j'aime bien ça change et ça fait quatre
mois que je regarde plus la télévision
je rallume la télévision tombe sur
madame est servie
je me dis rien n'a changé et ces
changements de la rampe les allemands
ont valu aux normes et oui alors j'ai
fait l'épilation vous allez faire la
mauvaise haleine la mauvaise haleine la
mauvaise haleine le bout du monde et la
mauvaise haleine c'est que nous on ne le
sent pas forcément mais l'autre il le
sent bien sûr ah bah oui
je ne vous le fais pas dire donc il faut
absolument réagir et on va voir à quoi
c'est dû à ce qu'on peut faire
le truc tout bête par exemple c'est de
se brosser la langue non mais ça mais
oui vous avez raison que ce soit quelque
chose d'avoir un personnel dans la
langue change rien du tout pour l'amour
et non bien ou mieux au milieu
oui bien donc ça je dirais encore bon
tous fouillés l'esthétique l'épilation
de mauvaise élève chez vous c'est un
petit peu familiale puisque
effectivement bon ses tournées lors de
la gueule chérie un peu parce que ouais
là là où je suis effondré c'est quoi
c'est qu'on vous confie une rubrique sur
la critique télévision éteignez chez
vous ici aussi
laure de lattre nettement est ce que
vous croyez pas que de la part de la
direction d'europe 1 c'est un peu se
[ __ ] de la gueule du monde de vous
confier une critique des émissions de
télévision
non c'est pas une critique c'est un
billet d'humeur j'ai vécu la télévision
pendant 70 jours
maintenant je découvre ce que c'est avec
un oeil de téléspectateurs maintenant je
suis dans la télévision
je vous vois en vrai et je pourrais leur
dire comment vous êtes en vrai ouais je
vous trouve très bien donc il y en aura
une
voit pas il est très gentil mesure pas
en quoi vous êtes qualifiés pour faire
ça en tant que telle la thaïlande maha
d'accord même sympa ou pas sympa toi tu
y étais tu as tu compris sérieusement en
tant que spectateur lambda
voilà pourquoi ce n'est pas un critique
de cinéma ou accusé d'utilisation
c'est quelqu'un qui s'intéresse au
cinéma rex / jours donc ça reste à la
télévision du monde s'interposait tout
le monde critique de télévision en fait
tout le monde peut donner son avis sur
la télévision et donc eurobank de
choisir ou non
europe 1 la critique sur la télévision
sera fait par tous les chroniqueurs de
yann qu ligue à tout de rôle donc une
semaine sur deux ce sera moi un jour
voilà c'est tout donc c'est quand même
très léger et ludique
voilà tu es riche vous inquiétez pas
alléchante l'inquiète pas je trouve ça
surréaliste je n'y a pas d'accord alors
quand vous avez entendu parler de love
story vous avez compris vous love story
oui un homme gentil et comme la loi est
bien que votre mère vous ai dit qu'aucun
garçon était à votre mesure dans le loft
bien que vous allez vous a dit ça on n'a
jamais eu aucun contact avec nos parents
vous ayez le béguin pour emmanuel chain
plus tôt mais oui on est pilote belge
voilà qui fait entrer de nouvelles
actions manuelles siens beaucoup plus
beaux prés qu'à la télévision
mais chacun son team daoui donc c'est
dans le loft que vous avez trouvé votre
mode jules weppe appris à fabriquer les
cheveux longs ah oui oui oui
sablé bien mais comment ça se sait
comment commencer par lille a fait
naître
ou bien tenu mais c'est de l'amour
vraiment si vous aimez beaucoup c'est de
la magie
non mais non mais c'est un droit sur
nous mais c'est surréaliste comédie de
rencontrer quelqu'un dans un jeu wii
luan à la haine et à saint tropez elle
est débordée toujours là bien sûr et
maëlle et à saint tropez n'allait
l'autre garçon dans une maison le gibus
et en fait dans cette maison c'est assez
étrange parce que la porte des toilettes
c'est une porte vitrée frappé pour
savoir si dix mois et a sérieusement
alors est-ce que c'est pas un peu tes
rides être maqué par l'intermédiaire
d'une maison de production
c'est vous qui choisissez moi j'ai
choisi de ne pas montrer nue pendant 70
jours je me suis bété en maillot c'est
vrai soixante dix loups en sortant je
suis déçu je me suis quand même douchée
en soutien gorge
ouais mais oui le breton
j'avais mon but c'est jamais refuser de
faire l'amour devant les caméras on met
ça moi aussi
tremblant
la motion
alors je sais quoi vous donner des coups
de cravache à tous
alors je pense alors comment ça s'est
passé des vacances avec votre jules
alors les vacances on est partis d'avoir
chacun de notre côté et après on est
parti sur pause et trouver de quoi faire
le point parce que ce qui nous arrive
l'été violent et ensuite on est parti à
miami a alors ça c'était très sympa en
effet miliani les keys les everglades et
orlando est occupé par un moustique qui
va défigurer la haine de la chasse
épreuve l'éditeur j'habitais ensemble
formule son père est là tout se passe
bien mais j'ai voulu apporter ses
valises chez vous il ya partout rôle des
gentils dit non je vais pas martel est
nommé ceinture formidable jeu génial pas
s'installer à la délicate comme evelyne
bouix et un it if the place un peu plus
sérieux oui michel où shell est ce que
vous connaissez loana mais souvenons il
à venir rien du tout au courant de rien
du tout ah bon
bien alors vous êtes effectivement il ya
quand même des choses qui se font pas ah
ouais
il
bien je pense à nous fait découvrir la
terre peña les plus gay qu'elle a même
causé par la plomberie hongrie nos coups
bas sinon vous auriez pas au centre
depuis aussi longtemps un bar vient
alors lors on vous dit effectivement
votre statut de la statue de stars est
un petit peu éphémère vous dit j'en suis
conscient mais oui mais disons suis
conscient on en reparlera dans huit
jours
oui on me dit que j'en suis consciente
effectivement nous sommes des gens un
peu ordinaire c'est bien là la bd pas
bien tu allais pas d'ordinaire alors
pour voir si vous êtes comme tout le
monde oui oui avoue non extraordinaire
vous non parce que vous vous êtes dans
la télévision et ça c'est magique et
nous on est devant et on vit j'aimerais
bien rentrer dedans vous êtes dedans
maintenant et assassinats alors tous
bords si vous êtes quelqu'un d'ordinaire
pour voir s'ils ont pensé comme tout le
monde on va vous faire une interview
opinion plus par la bouche